the hockey mask wearing machete toting
Jason Voorhees has terrorized
unsuspecting teens since Friday the 13th
hit screens in 1980 the franchise has
produced 12 movies a TV show a series of
comics and a few brutal video games but
audiences still want more take a look
behind the mask to see how he became one
of the most recognizable movie monsters
of all time
he is the untold truth of Friday the
13th save the date following his work on
Wes Craven's The Last House on the Left
director producer Sean Cunningham sought
to capitalize on the growing slasher
movie trend in a pretty brilliant
marketing move cunningham took out an ad
promoting the film before he had any
financial backing he called the
unscripted film Friday the 13th
mimicking the date specific theme set by
the Halloween series the strategy worked
and his word spread of what the ads
called the most terrifying movie ever
made investors actually started reaching
out to him he found himself with a
budget for a film with a title but no
plot or characters so why Friday the
13th Jason was my son and today is his
birthday
Joshua Voorhees Miller originally wrote
the character of Jason Voorhees as Josh
but changed it to avoid giving him the
same name as his own son
Joshua and because really Josh takes
Manhattan probably wouldn't have quite
the same ring to it at the time the
character's name have little
significance he wasn't even written to
appear in the film until later drafts
and even then only in his mother's dream
sequences masked murderer Jason didn't
take his iconic masked form until Friday
the 13th Part three while the original
character was created by screenwriter
Victor Miller and director Sean s
Cunningham the hockey mask was a
contribution from part three director
Steve miner to replace Jason's usual
burlap sack even done a whole bunch of
of hockey documentaries you know why and
I when it was when he was learning the
alien craft and I think that just out of
that is should well let's at least try
this and end it that's was the choice
for Friday 3 and I just stuffed the mask
worn by Jason in part 3 was replicated
from a Detroit Red Wings goalie mask and
variations appeared throughout the rest
of the series
- suggestion of the hockey mask secured
Jason as an icon
figure making him the master of terror
that we know today Camp Crystal Lake
Camp anobii Bosco or the North Bergen
boys girls camp has been operational
since 1927 but you might know it better
as Camp Crystal Lake the New Jersey
summer camp runs regular day tours of
the grounds to satisfy the curiosities
of horror fans but Nobby Bosco is
otherwise reserved exclusively for Boy
Scout activities according to the
official site the hundred dollar ticket
sell out quickly but they're good for a
five hour guided tour of all the key
massacre locations if you can't make it
out to Jason's blood-stained stomping
grounds you can buy a chunk of the
original Camp Crystal Lake dock a slice
of log cabin or a bottle of water from
the lake in which young Jason famously
drowned kill her mommy
Friday the third team signature sound
queue is actually the voice of composer
Howie Manfredini Cunningham approached
Manfredini to create a musical cue that
would characterize a presence of the
unseen killer magnified any took a cue
from the film itself when Jason's mother
does those terrifying words Manfredini
repeated the words applied a heavy
reverb to his voice and the result
became iconic the effect that was
initially created to foreshadow mrs.
Voorhees would cue the presence of Jason
in all the new films to follow a new car
after failing to cast Shelley Winters
for the role of mrs. Voorhees the
production team sought out veteran
television actress Betsy Palmer who
initially turned it down upon reading
the script which she thought was awful
Parma eventually caved and took the role
because she desperately needed a new car
and truly I only did the darn thing to
buy a car I really didn't at the end of
filming she could afford a Volkswagen
Scirocco she changed her mind after
production began when effects artist Tom
Savini showed us some pictures of his
effects work when a picture of the
effects for the young deformed Jason
came up he told her that's your son from
that point on Palmer gained sympathy for
Pamela Voorhees and delivered a
performance that would become a
milestone of her career best body count
Jason skills up in tallied at numbers
ranging between 158 and 300 but it's
still unanimous that Jason is
responsible for more on-screen
fatalities than any of his horror
villain contemporaries the wide margin
of error is attributed to mrs. Voorhees
being the original killer a grief sick
father emulating Jason in part five and
because many of his kills and Freddy vs.
Jason are attributable to Freddy via
mind control even the lower-end figure
lands Jason miles ahead of Freddy
Krueger Michael Myers or Leatherface
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Friday the
13th film is your favorite
you
[Music]